hey youtubers is Charlie so yesterday I
asked you to submit all of your arrow
and flash questions so I picked 10 of
them to answer in this video with one
bonus question generally everyone had a
lot of questions about Amanda Waller and
Hong Kong but since Stephen Amell has
started teasing what's gonna be
happening in season 3 we actually have a
lot more interesting stuff to talk about
real quick if you're finding me for the
first time I try to do Marvel and DC
videos every week be sure to subscribe
to get everything
also I'm working on a special Star Wars
Episode 7 spin-off video for later
tonight and I'm getting to see
Maleficent so that review is gonna post
on Friday now let's talk about the
unholy union of Amanda Waller and Oliver
and some flash whatnot so question one
comes from Jedi Knight do you think
we'll ever get to see Slade's son in
present day so you're talking about
Jericho yes I definitely think we'll
eventually see him
Jericho appearing is completely
dependent upon slays role on the show if
they use him as part of the larger story
that I think it would be a really good
opportunity to bring Jericho on even if
they decide not to feature Slade though
they could always bring on a new
character under a false name and they
just develop him into like the new Roy
type persona cut to the end of the
season and we find out that it's really
Jericho in disguise but he has no idea
what slate did in season 2 or that
Oliver was responsible for putting him
in an Argus prison they mentioned him a
couple times between season 1 and season
2 so they have to show him eventually or
at least tell us what happened to him
when Slade was marooned on the island
I'd really like to know is Slade ever
tried to contact him after he escaped
the island but he was pretty juiced up
with mirakuru so I would not be
surprised if he didn't question number 2
jaemor asks where did Slade's powers and
enhanced brain function go and will they
use the metahuman plot on the flash TV
show to give Laurel Real Black Canary
powers so when the mirakuru in his
bloodstream went away all the benefits
went away to the mirakuru was mostly a
drug for repairing human tissue that
also just happened to bestow
super-strength
it didn't make Slade super smart like he
is in the comics they changed all that
he's still super clever but the only
real mental side effects of the mirakuru
were giving him shado hallucinations and
no I don't think that Laurel is gonna
become a metahuman even if she did they
do it on arrow and not on the flash the
crossover material that they do for air
on flash will be more about them trying
to defeat a common villain it's unclear
how involved Oliver is going to get in
the whole particle accelerator explosion
dark energy plot that's going on in the
flash that we saw in the trailer my
guess is is that all the new metahumans
will get their powers from that so if
you are not in Central City in the blast
radius when that went off you're not
going to become a metahuman at least
based on that question number three Coco
tix asks since Oliver is in Hong Kong
will we get new characters in the
flashbacks totally I'm also expecting to
see some familiar faces too as for who
some of those characters might be I
think it'll mostly be International
superheroes and villains otherwise why
make it happen in Hong Kong it's such a
port of call on that side of the world
you know naturally a lot of criminal
elements in the DC Universe would pass
through there at some point
Amanda Waller as teased during season 1
was there to destabilize the Chinese
government presumably the flashbacks
will tell that story and explain what
else she was doing there
question number 4 malicious asks do you
think that Komodo or onomatopoeia is
going to be a major or minor villain in
arrow season 3 so I think that Komodo is
more likely but they actually gave a lot
of his character traits and things about
him to Slade in season 2 in the comics
Komodo creates this major plan to make
all of our lose all his money and Oliver
shoots one of his eyes out with an arrow
so they've already combined a lot of
that character with Deathstroke but it's
totally possible that they could use the
character and just change the backstory
to focus more on his history with shado
if you're not familiar with Komodo his
real name is Simon Lacroix and he just
grew up working for Queen industries
Robert Queen Oliver's father taught him
to use a bow and eventually he turned
evil question number five John Harper
asks do you think that John Diggle will
become Green Lantern if not do you think
that the Green Lantern will be in arrow
or flash so I don't think they would do
something like you know bestowing that
kind of power on a character without a
big multi-season arc it's like way too
big for just one season but because how
Dourdan is the most iconic Green Lantern
I think that the flash TV show would get
first crack at teasing that character
just because Jordan is also a central
city character they have teased fares
airlines already so I do think we'll get
more Green Lantern teasers regardless if
they do anything with Diggle related to
Green Lantern I think it'll just be
having and make some jokes about Green
costumes rings or making him rhyme
something like the Green Lantern motto
in terms of actually seeing a physical
Green Lantern character on arrow the
flash definitely I think that's gonna
happen eventually because the movie at
Warner Brothers flopped so bad I think
they're gonna be much more willing to
let the character come to television you
know normally they kind of hold like
Superman and Batman up just as like
movie characters because they make so
much money it did take about two years
to get to Barry Allen though so do not
expect another spin-off character like
that until arrow season 4 or like flash
season 2 question number 6 jack up and
asks hey Charlie how about a shout out
my birthday is on Saturday so everybody
be sure to give Jack a birthday
high-five happy birthday buddy question
number 7 Daedalus asks what other non
natural abilities or powers will appear
on arrow so it looks like they've been
able to do a pretty good job with
weather and energy based effects just
looking at the flash trailer because
Oliver's not a superhuman though I think
they're just gonna steer away from comic
book characters with crazy powers at
least on arrow it just makes more sense
to put Oliver next to other characters
with similar abilities there are always
exceptions to that and its name right
now is Barry Allen but he's only gonna
be right next to Oliver on screen a
couple times this year the flash TV show
is a whole different story because he's
got crazy powers via the Speed Force
those limitations you have with Oliver
or characters like Oliver are totally
out the window just because I am a
sucker for the classics I think some of
the first powers we do you get to see
will be like the rogue based powers like
Captain cold freezing stuff push number
Adrian asks do you think we'll get to
see the League of Assassins in the Hong
Kong flashbacks that would be so awesome
I think well at least see some
references to them I don't think they're
gonna be the primary antagonist like ed
fiers was on the island Oliver did say
that he heard things about Raja Ghul so
he had to hear them from somewhere it
does stand to reason that that place
where he heard all about him could be
Hong Kong question number 9 Niloy asks
is there gonna be any reference to the
flashpoint storyline on the flash TV
series so they're starting off the
with a modified version of rebirth and
the new 52 origin story Geoff Johns is
writing on the staff and he wrote flash
for a long time so expect lots of
references to Golden Age Silver Age and
recent flash stuff flash point included
but since flashpoint was such a universe
altering event I think they're just
gonna make references to it the particle
accelerator explosion is kind of the
MacGuffin for season one with the dark
energy it released creating all these
new metahumans that's gonna be where
they mined most of the story from week
to week so that's probably the closest
you'll get to like a flashpoint universe
altering event question number 10 Alex
asks do you think we'll see Felicity
flashbacks from before she met Oliver so
originally whenever Stephen Amell teased
about us learning more about Felicity in
season 2 he made it sound like we were
supposed to see a lot more stuff and
then maybe they shot it and it got cut
out at the last minute I don't expect to
see a lot of that cut out stuff in
flashbacks like we get with Hong Kong in
the island but I do think Felicity will
start talking about her past before she
met everyone or at least talk about it
more than she has in the past usually it
takes something really traumatic to
happen to a character before they start
talking about their past lot so I think
something with Felicity's family is
gonna happen that makes her really upset
and she's just gonna start talking to
Oliver about it I don't think she's
gonna get like a solo episode where she
goes off on her own without team arrow
for an entire hour though so if we do
learn more about Felicity I think it
will be a present day and she'll just be
talking about things that happened to
her or we'll meet that family and one
last bonus question
Lord Laxton asks do you think that
they'll introduce a new super villain in
season 3 like they did in season 2 when
they brought on Barry Allen so you're
actually just asking like are they gonna
bring someone new on the show that it's
a comic book character they just big
enough to sustain their own spin-off you
know like a really big villain character
I think they'll definitely bring someone
in who can stand by themselves they'd
have to just to top Deathstroke but I
think whoever it ends up being will be
more of a lateral move like they're not
gonna go with a super villain that has
crazy superpowers it'll be someone like
Deathstroke or Merlin who Oliver
actually has a chance of defeating you
know with a little help from Felicity of
course I'm sure whatever Comic Con comes
along Stephen Amell will be teasing more
season
three villains stuff so that's probably
when we're gonna get our best info so
thank you so much everyone for
submitting your questions my next arrow
and flash video will post next Wednesday
be sure to subscribe to get everything
feel free to leave me suggestions for
bonus topics too and like I said I'm
also working on a special Star Wars
video that I'm going to post like late
late tonight and then I'm seeing
Maleficent so that review will post on
Friday right now click here to get that
Star Wars video and you can click here
to learn more about arrow season 3 thank
you so much for watching I'll see you
guys tomorrow high fives